I'm Peter Levine only teach em avoids
the insurance market in London I know
there's been a lot of talk here in the
first round whirled about the financial
problems that have happened one thing I
would like people are saying internet
online I say this is chairman of Lloyd's
insurance market with the nosc back is
the insurance industry's come out of
this pretty well and we're in good shape
well what throughout the period before
anybody says AIG I think you'll find
that most of their geez problems came
from their financial products business
not their insurance business but I think
it seems easy to demonize people quite a
number is probably need demonizing but
we must be sure that the baby doesn't it
turn out the bath water everybody the
whole world needs a good strong and able
financial system which we had until
several years ago and it's up to the
industry it's up to governments and
regulators to get it right and I think
it's up to everybody else to impress on
the need to get it right but without
demonizing and trying to help them
through it I'm trying to explain that
they need good reasonable financial
services which they need out of my
personal life of their businesses and i
think im gonna try least two work
together on it we might get a better
outcome thank you